معنا من غلاف غزه مراسله الجزيره نجوان
سمري نجوان اذا الساعات ال 24 الماضيه
شهدت اصابه 19 جنديا اسرائيليا هل من
معطيات اكثر بهذا الخصوص وبخصوص كذلك
المستوى العسكري للعمليات
وتيرتها نعم هذا الاعلان للجيش الاسرائيلي
عن عدد الاصابات في الساعات ال
2 الماضيه لكن بطبيعه الحال في ساعات
المساء سنرى ما ستعلنه المستشفيات
الاسرائيليه التي تستقبل الجنود المصابين
من ارض المعركه وبالعاده يكون هناك فجوه
وتكون الاعداد التي ت تنشرها قوائم
المستشفيات اعلى مما ينشره الجيش
الاسرائيلي وفقا لما نرصده كل يوم ووفقا
للمعطيات ايضا التي اكدتها عده تحقيقات
لوسائل اعلام اسرائيليه بهذا الشان من جهه
العمليات العسكريه مازال الجيش الاسرائيلي
يتحدث عن ان تركيز عملياته الحربيه تتركز
اكثر في منطقه الوسط ولكن تحديدا في محور
مدينه خان يونس صباح هذا اليوم اعلن بانه
هاجم 30 هدفا فقط في منطقه خان يونس وهو
يكرر عمليا غالبيه البيانات التي يصدرها
في الايام الاخيره الماضيه وحتى منذ
الاسابيع الاخيره الماضيه بعد ان ب بدا
توغله البري في محور خان يونس والمنطقه ال
الجنوبيه يتحدث طيله الوقت عن استهداف
لمقاومين فلسطينيين والعثور على بنى تحتيه
ومواقع
ومستودعات او مبان يجد بها حسب بياناته
وسائل قتاليه وفوهات انفاق هذا ما يتحدث
عنه الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي طيله الوقت
في محاوله لوصف ذلك بانه انجازات يحققها
الجيش
على حد تعبيره لكن نعيد ونكرر حتى غالبيه
الخبراء الاسرائيليين والمحللين
والمراسلين العسكريين يتحدثون او يصفون
هذه الانجازات التي يحققها الجيش
الاسرائيلي بانها انجازات تكتيكيه عمليات
في الميدان ولكنها لا تقترب من الاهداف
الاستراتيجيه التي وضعتها الحكومه
والكابينه ومجلس الحرب لهذه الحرب سواء
كان بالقضاء على حركه حماس سلطويا وعسكريا
او اعاده المحتجزين الاسرى الاسرائيليين
من غزه وكذلك ايضا الغاء اي خطر من غزه
على البلدات الغلاف او الا تشكل غزه اي
خطر وفقا لتعبيرات المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
على
امن المنطقه في الغلاف وايضا لم يتم اعاده
ال ال سكان البلدات الحدوديه في المناطق
الشماليه منذ ساعات الصباح كان هناك عده
مرات قذف مدفعي متقطع وتيره اقل بكثير من
السابق التي كنا نشهدها في الاسابيع
الاخيره نتحدث عن منطقه الشمال فقط وسيله
بيت حنون وبيت لاهيه واطراف جباليا هي تلك
التي نستطيع ان نرصدها من هذه المواقع
وايضا في بعض الاحيان تسمع او يسمع دوي
انفجارات ونسمعه الان بالعاده يكون ناجم
عن تفجيرات يقوم بها سلاح الهندسه التابع
للجيش الاسرائيلي لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لتفجير عدد من المباني
والمنشات في بعض الاحيان يعلن في بياناته
بانها بنى تحتيه وانفاق لكن في كثير من
مقاطع الفيديو التي ينشرها جنود في
الميدان نرى بانهم يقومون بتفجير مبان لم
تتدمر جراء القذف المدفعي او القصف الجوي
لكن من جهه اخرى طيله الوقت هناك حديث عن
اليوم التالي في هذه
الحرب تحديدا انتقال الجيش الى المرحله
الثالثه او المرحله الاقل كثافه من حيث
اطلاق النيران والقصف تحديدا في من في
المناطق الشماليه صباح هذا اليوم نشرت
مقابله مع وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف
جالاند في صحيفه الوول ستريت جورنال ونشر
في اعقابها بانه اعلن الانتقال الى هذه
المرحله لكن سرعان ما اصدر مكتب جلنت في
تل ابيب بيانا توضيحيا قال فيه بان جالانت
قال للصحيفه ان الجيش سينتقل قريبا ولم
ينتقل الى هذه المرحله وليس في كل قطاع
غزه وانما فقط في المناطق الشماليه بينما
يستمر القتال وفقا للمرحله الثانيه التي
توغل فيها الجيش بريا الى داخل غزه في
المناطق الوسطى وفي المناطق الجنوبيه هذه
التصريحات كانت قد اثارت بطبيعه الحال غضب
نواب او اع ضاء في الكابينت من الجناح
الاكثر تطرفا في هذه الحكومه لا سما وكما
هو متوقع اتمار بن كفير الذي غرد مباشره
ونشر بان هذا الاعلان او هذه المقابلات
الصحفيه مع وسائل اعلام غربيه لوزراء في
الكابينت ومجلس الحرب يتحدثون فيها عن
انتهاء المرحله الثانيه من الحرب
والانتقال والانتقال الى مرحله اخرى انما
هي انتقال من حرب ل لاخضاع حركه حماس وحرب
حسم الى حرب استنزاف واضاف بانه لا يوجد
تفويض لمجلس الحرب بالاعلان عن مثل هذه
الاجراءات والانتقال الى مرحله اخرى في
الحرب وهذا التصريح مره اخرى يدل على عمق
الازمه في داخل بين الكابينت وهو يعتبر
المجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون الامنيه
والاسرائيليه وبينك فير وسموت اعضاء
فيه وطله الوقت ينتقدون القرارات التي
يتخذها مجلس الحرب ولذلك نرى نتنياهو في
كثير من الاحيان يرضخ لهم ويلغي اجتماعات
لمجلس الحرب او يغير المواضيع والملفات
التي ستبحث فيه اشكرك جزيل الشكر نجوان
سمري مراسلتنا من غلاف غزه